we want to talk in some depth about this
language called PostScript and how
important it is but it's in the very
nature of PostScript that it uses a
notation called postfix and that in turn
relies for its execution environment on
this notion of a stack now we haven't
covered stacks so far in computer file
so before getting into PostScript
full-blown as it were I have got to tell
you something about stacks and we may be
in a position to put this out as a
separate film in its own right doing a
bit about stacks first of all mentioning
PostScript from time to time but it's
important that you realize that stacks
are a much wider application in computer
science than just two PostScript a plus
B what could be more commonplace than
that in any language that you program
then and that plus in the middle is an
operator it takes in this case a couple
of operands it combines them together it
does the addition so these of course
things like plus minus multiply divide
raise to the power of our examples of
arithmetic operators but they need the
operands to work on notice that the
operator the addition comes in between
the operands the a and the B and because
it's inserted and inscribed inside the
two operands that's why this is called
an inner fix use well we're all very
familiar with inner fixit's what we
taught at high school and what we use
most of the time it's perfectly possible
to write like that using a prefix plus
you'll say plus a B that's prefix
notation basically if you read it out
you're saying add together a and B yeah
you're putting the plus at the start so
it precedes the operands so it's prefix
and just to make it clear that this is
something you are familiar with
sometimes if you have a language
that defines addition not so much with
an operator but with a function call you
say add add a comma B and the arguments
or the operands are in parentheses what
happens if you write it so that it comes
after the operands ah we're here at last
this is postfix a gentleman who was a
mathematical logician from Poland called
triangular spelling right I think his
name is pronounced on and like
Yanukovych because that hell becomes a
faint soft W sound with the crossbar he
was a mathematical logician and what he
said was do you know if I write stuff
out like this as either prefix or
postfix it's so much easier for me to
prove mathematical theorems with tell
you I know its net result of all this
was that people being unable to
pronounce his name correctly and getting
all the stresses and accents wrong
decided that rather than pronouncing
what they found hard they would call
this polish notation now actually polish
notation applies to using anything that
isn't in fixed I've seen prefix notation
being called forward polish notation
I've seen this a b-plus given its
traditional name or of reverse polish
notation but that's where it came from
the gentleman who invented it sometimes
this is even abbreviated to a thing you
may also have seen RPN reverse polish
notation
it saves the interpreter or the compiler
an awful lot of effort in actually
executing the expressions that you write
write down
let's keep very simple again 2a plus B
if I write a plus B like that and let's
say we'll see what the C language
compiler would do to it what would they
have to do to it how would it translate
it into binary I don't want to do
strings of meaning as binary with you
but I'll tell you what I will do I'll
try and translate that as if I was the C
compiler into assembly code now the
assembly code will depend on whether on
an ARM chip and Intel chip or whatever
and some of you will know the GCC
compiler gives a flag on there as well
as an option which says show me the
assembler code that you would produce
for this and here goes I'm making this
up it might not correspond to any
particular assembly you know but I hope
you'll get the idea
load register r1 with a the compiler
will store off the values of a and B in
memory but as you all know before they
can be added together they've got to be
lifted into the central processor unit
of the computer and then when they're
added you call up the arithmetic unit
inside the CPU load register command
register - this time with B add what is
in register 1 - what is in register 2
and put the answer in register 3 roughly
similar to the last assembler language I
taught which was for the ARM chip don't
castigate here forgot some of the
details wrong but I hope that's just to
give you the idea just look at what it
has to do it has to get a get B and do
the addition you have to do it that way
because you can't do anything with
something until you get them first and
lift it into the CPU and put it in
registers just look at this what it does
it gets a into a register it gets B into
another register it adds them together
puts the answer somewhere in the third
register a B add a B plus its postfix
notation for even more complicated
things it has to convert it into reverse
polish explicitly or implicitly in order
to decide what code to generate and what
the cache of it's really loved about
this absolutely thought it was ace when
he discovered it is the following
suppose we now write a plus B star C
which one of these addition or
multiplication operators takes
precedence answer
it's the multiply the multiply must be
done first everybody knows that and if
you don't want it to be done first you
have to deliberately force it to be done
the other way so let's be clear this one
says multiply the B by C because
multiply is more powerful than ad and
when you've got the answer there add it
to a this one says I want you to add a
and B and then multiply by C what will
cash of each said this is fantastic he
said in my proofs I hate parentheses
they mess things up but you realize that
you don't have to parentheses because in
reverse polish this comes out to be a b
c star plus whereas this one comes out
to be a b plus c star i'm telling you
that a plus B times C or to translate
that in postfix reverse polish whatever
you want to call it the reason it does
you've got to be careful here let me
remind you of what you will all have
been taught at high school is that
multiply is a stronger operator than add
multiplication takes precedence as the
phrase goes so in here to get the right
answer you multiply B times C first of
all and then you do the add because it's
of lower precedence so if all these are
fives a being say they all represent the
number 5 you get 5 times 5 is 25 25 plus
5 is 30 the way that this is represented
in a reverse polish is as follows a b c
multiply + and the way that this works
is that when you get an operator it is
going to apply to the each foo
immediately preceding operands because
that's what those fix is all about the
more you look at that the more you
realize and computer scientists when
they looked at reverse polish notation
in the late forties and early fifties
just thought all their Christmases have
come up once not only was this what we
need
did for compiling stuff and getting use
of usage of registers and CPUs
absolutely right but also it related
very much to a data structure that
they're in the process of realizing its
power the stack now there's a lot of
computer science depends on stacks I
sometimes think that stacks and trees is
just about all computer science is about
but it's the first time we've mentioned
them I think on computer file so I'll
try and go very very gently with you
about this this is a stack why is it a
snack it's a start because you can
so-called push things on it I'm going to
push something else on to the top of the
stack notice that I can only access
things by taking them off this rod so
therefore it's a last thing in first
thing out storage mechanism I'm going to
push the light able to stack with three
objects on it
the only easy one to get out is the top
of the stack and if I take it off like
that
that's called popping a stack so you
push it on the top and you pop the top
of the stack like that let's be clear in
all of this word that I shall be doing
now with disks and stacks I'm using
these disks here to be of different
sizes simply so you can see which is
which on the stack I'm producing there's
no implication that the biggest disk
represents the biggest integer or
anything like that
I'll try and be clear as I as I go along
as to which one represents a which one
represents B which one represents C or
maybe which one represents some partial
intermediate result William multiplied
two things together or whatever so don't
get mesmerized
too much by the size of these things
this is a case where size doesn't matter
you've just got to remember which is
which well if we're pushing and popping
then how does that relate to this
reverse polish this postfix for that
expression let's call this big one here
the a
and on to push a so the rule then for
interpreting reverse polish notation is
if it's an operand push it on the stack
be is that an operand yes push it on the
stack see another operand push it on the
stack next one multiply our well the
rule about interpreting reverse polish
on a stack is to say if you hit an
operator think to yourself how many
operands does this got then take them
off the stack those two operands in this
case do the operation and push the
answer back so I take off C and I take
off it B multiply them together so I've
got a B times C intermediate result now
which I represent with this smaller one
here remember this one is the B times C
sub of result and having done that
multiply the rule is you push the
intermediate answer back on the stack
coming to the end of the reverse polish
string here you'll see as a final plus
what does plus mean plus means it's
expects two operands and we're fortunate
we've got it right there's two things on
the stack as our original a and as the
intermediate result that we've pushed
back on of doing B times C so for the
plus you take them both off you do an ad
like that you produce the final answer
which is this very small disk here and
in PostScript and in most of the systems
when you've got the final answer you
leave it at the top of the stack like
that so the answer for a plus B times C
has been evaluated using a stack and
reverse polish and the final answer has
appeared on top of the stack so for
interpreted languages with expressions
of this sort reverse polish postfix is
its other name don't forget and stacks
they just go together perfectly they
were built in heaven for one another
without a question
you've got a third a third a third we
have coped with that we've cope with
that if you get a choice of either that
pair or that pair of thirds it doesn't
matter which actually okay so now we've
got one sort of list